be in the room you're not Don Draper I  think ya be judicious with it with the  photographs you take because you know  photo of your daughter  crowning hanging on the refrigerator  that's not going to help anyone so your  wife will pretty much never think it's  funny or charming if you tip your  imaginary top hat and say add your  cervix don't don't go to that you really  want to realize that you're pretty much  the least important thing in the room  you know it's going to go your wife your  baby the doctor the nurse a doula if you  have one the air God the air  and when your wife asks if everything's  okay down there just responding the  affirmative you know don't don't yell  and yell better than ever